well there are a lot of things going on
in the world right now that make
make you feel angry frustrated or upset
i understand
so we asked one of the most optimistic
people we know guy benson to help find
some
good news buried under all of the
negativity so
guy i heard that hillary clinton has a
political thriller coming out can you
give us a preview please
oh yes katie i am very pleased to report
that the rumors
are true america's hottest novelist is
back
she's fresh off of her last fictional
work what happened
and she's bringing us more which is very
exciting
and the thing that i've learned i'm a
big fan of the genre
thrillers if you want a great thriller
you typically will have
multiple plot lines that all come
together for an explosive unexpected
ending to the book this is what brad
thor does for example
and i don't want to give any spoilers
right but i have read an advanced copy
and i'm going to tell you about the
three plot lines
oh my gosh what happens at the end so
this is exclusive okay plot line number
one
there are american troops and cia
officers
trapped under enemy fire in northern
africa what's gonna happen
okay the second plot line is top
secret u.s intelligence has fallen into
the hands
of a hostile power it was pilfered
from the illegal unsecured email server
of a high-ranking american official
i mean scary stuff really amazing and
finally
a mysterious accused pedophile
billionaire turns up dead in federal
custody
who done it you'll have to find out in
this masterpiece
and i'll just say when it comes to
fiction they always tell you
write what you know and by god hillary's
done it
so proud of her and i think this one's
going to be a mega hit there is this
thing called faction guy
and i've heard that there's a lot of
faction which is a mix between fiction
and
fact in this political thriller i look
forward to
learning more about it from you so thank
you for the exclusive on that um
moving to new york now they are trying
to fight crime
with robot dogs your take on that
well i have a very long standing policy
katie
of commenting on robots in the most
glowing terms possible because
when the cylons come and take over i
want to be on the record very clearly in
favor of robots and our future overlords
so i think that these robotic dogs are
not creepy at
all they're not terrifying or
you know a sign of a coming dystopia i
think it's just wonderful and i hope
that they will spare me when they're in
charge
all right what else do you have for me
guy we need one more piece of good news
well i did hear that better o'rourke is
widely reported
to be running for governor or at least
considering lucky times
2022 down in texas and i'm pro-life i
know you're pro-life that means every
life and if that means giving someone
something to live for beto needs that
right now which is another political run
in that state it seems like the one
thing that really sustains him in this
world
and look good luck to him convincing
voters in texas that
the beto that we saw in the 2020
presidential campaign who's way out
there on the left isn't really
the better 3.0 or whatever the new
iteration is going to be when he runs
for governor
that's going to be a challenge for him
but he'll have a purpose again
and that's always really wonderful and
exciting to see how could we forget when
he was on the cover of vanity fair
and they said born to be in it
so another flashback to beto 2.0
or robert francis orc so guy benson
thank you for bringing the joy tonight
we appreciate it